i love this man and i don't care who
knows it and i would say it even if he
wasn't on hold listening to me right now
on the mercedes-benz van phone line
about to join us um from curb your
enthusiasm which is returned for season
11 god bless that show and the goldberg
season nine wow boy does this man a big
bowl of staying power with jeff garland
how are you jeffrey what's up i'm i'm
staying i'm staying
i've got the power to stay and i'm
staying bless you how are you and by the
way um
uh uh i am so happy and lucky to have
two shows run for 900 years that's great
i don't know how i pulled it up by the
way equal with my luck for that is my
unluckiness of being a fan of a mad
naggy coach team
[Laughter]
ryan page has put together the most
beautiful squad that has ever seen in
nfl surf
if only nfl films could do a classic
john fasenda episode about how bad the
bears suck
and that was when the bears sucked worse
as justin fields was brought to the turf
for ninth time by the cleveland browns
like that that sort of thing
yep yep okay you know what like that
tampa bay game was worse than the
cleveland game
if you ask me okay i will ask you why
was it worse than the cleveland game
jeff
it was worse because
we we put tom brady all day long into a
situation of him going oh all right i'm
going to do this
you know there was no challenges for tom
brady that day and we got to put our
defense at worst when we're on offense
in a position right like when we play
cleveland the defense played great but
this was beyond and what's what i by the
way when you have trouble giving credit
to your offensive coordinator for being
the uh uh the calling the place and you
can't even do that when they did
all right you know what my as my friend
brad moore no he didn't say it someone
told him so i don't know who to give
credit to but somebody deserves credit
here's the premise everything you need
to know about maggie is in this he's a
bald man wearing a visor
i have had you need more than that hold
on
[Music]
now here's the deal jeff um i have
brought this subject up to matt nagy on
this program as a fellow member of the
bald brotherhood i told him to wear the
ball cap
that
that that as a fellow member of the bald
brotherhood that the um
the
visor not only does it leave him open to
sunburn and things of that nature just
for no no no no no safety reasons skin
cancer i don't wish it on him of course
i'm not that kind of but i just said it
it accentuates the baldness is what i'm
saying so by the way
which by the way as a bald man you
should respect because you'd go look at
you throwing it out there because you
know larry david famously said in terms
of dating the hat has to come off
sometime
[Laughter]
it's it's not just it's not just the the
visor it's also the headset going across
so you've got you've got a circumference
and then you've got sort of a bisecting
situation and it's just you know
wrong but by the way as bad as that is
not as bad as a slave calling good night
everybody hi i'm ryan pace i'd like to
trade you
um uh uh
kelly mack you have a pennant you have a
pennant or maybe uh a box of fudge i
will trade him for you because i have no
clue
careful
jeff garland here on the rich eisen show
going all march on lynch like it's the
manning cast uh hey well by the way i'm
really you know look i've not been on
your show
at all uh for uh for different personal
reasons no
we always miss you jeffrey come on now i
appreciate it but i'm really
i'm in a tizzy about and by the way
let's jump now to another ship
the blackhawks
the blackhawks how do they recover from
this when your coaches are having sex
with your players
you got a problem you know when you go
in to watch video and you end up
watching video that doesn't really help
you as a hockey player i know it's awful
jeff it's terrible man i agree with you
and i'm like you know i've always liked
the rangers which is you where you live
and um not live live but live yeah your
favorite team
and i'm thinking maybe i'll just jump
larry loves the rangers maybe i'll just
jump ship with him my friend mitchell
whitfield loves the ranger i've been too
many a rager game i've yelled popped and
sucked
why not jump on the rangers maybe you
should and get off the embarrassment
train jeff garland here on the rich
eisen show you just mentioned how uh
larry david loves the new york rangers
which opens me up to placing in front of
you
something that larry david said on this
show when he was here
last wednesday okay two wednesdays ago
okay
now he said that when he he records
rangers games and also sometimes plays
golf when the jets play
and that jeff schaefer who you know
because he's the director of curb your
enthusiasm as well as the collaborators
everything
correct he's one of the other executive
producers correct correct the three of
us right so you're all you you know
jeffrey shea for very well jeff garlic i
love jeff schafer
well larry was very upset with jeff the
other day as you mentioned here because
all right because jeff shaffer just
blurted out on text about the jet score
and j larry said that that is a no-no
that you should though he uses his worms
always assume tape
and i said for a live sporting event
that's asking a lot of somebody that
you're assuming somebody take a jump
back yeah you want my opinion on it yes
that's what that's what i'm saying yes
your opinion uh if he's mad at the jets
because they put out a score
uh he's overstepped his pounds you don't
put out a score on twitter you don't do
that okay because there are people who
wait sometimes i i'm doing something i
have to wait especially with the bears
now the bears are not must-see for me
now even though i have the package and i
i watch right for the most part by the
way
[Music]
no i agree with larry
oh i got to tell you come on now i mean
this is live sports you get no hold on
hold on hold on you don't tweet out of
the score no you don't no he texted him
he says hey how about those jets or
something like that you know it's what
he said and larry got upset with jess i
don't care you don't say anything you
don't you should know better now you're
rich eisens yes sir if somebody follows
you and they think oh i'm not going to
ever get in the nfl news then they're
ignorant and if you send it out and
they're mad at you then they're ignorant
you're going to get alpha you're rich
eisen he's jeff shaffer he's in the
world of comedy leave the jets out of
this
by the way i called larry david the
other day because i was curious after
most recent jets lost i said let me ask
you a question do you like the coach or
is he just faced with the worst
situation i love the coach worse
situation yeah so there you go i'm with
you i'm i'm with that too to be honest
with you by the way yeah we we have the
potential to have a really good
offensive defense when i say we you know
i own the bears yes so i want to
announce that i'm firing matt nagy and
ryan pace today and we're replacing them
with a mentally challenged 10 year old
well jeff um listen uh i i don't think
you own the bears i thought aaron
rodgers owned the bears
jeff by the way all right let's jump to
that for a second all right
how do you know all right so the woman
gives him the double bird and he yells i
own you to everyone and uh my opinion is
he does he does he does he has he will
oh if you're a chicago bear fan and you
have trouble with what he said you're an
idiot because he owns us
he owns this he's single-handedly
uh keeping the the uh the fight between
the packers and the bears alive because
he you got a root you know whereas i
hate the vikings i respect the packers
respect them so much uh they kind of
screwed things up this past year with
aaron rodgers but mark my words aaron
rodgers will finish his career a bear
no no i i just threw that in to see if
you were listening i'm saying
i'm paying strict detention jeff i'm
paying for it he owns us he certainly
can afford to pay himself oh my gosh
that's true
all right jeff are you calling from the
set of one of your many shows is that
what you're doing right now no i'm
actually calling from my desk in my
office
okay iphone 12. i had an iphone 13 but i
got the small one hands too big i got
back to the iphone 12. all right so the
goldberg's wednesday at eight eastern on
abc season nine yes you're the yes gruff
somewhat a social patriarch of the
goldbergs that's the notes that i've
been doing better than i am okay very
good not remotely growth on curb my
character curve's not growth i'd love it
i mean dude yeah i get that i get to
really swing out my range
hey
listen to me yes i there's two things i
want yes one is you already said yes but
we haven't been able to arrange and that
is me being your only guest for the
whole show that's of that any time
and also i'm here to relieve you you're
using other people what are you doing
because see i know what it is you're
afraid people will love me so much what
to say
rich yeah
they're gonna say rich who when you're
gone no i do not i do not fear being
wally pipped by you jeff garland i do
not fear that by the way do you remember
you know this is not even i mean this is
long ago but it was normal to have guest
shows on every talk show i know that and
i'm totally up for that i just know that
when this gets played back later on
unless she's listening right now my wife
who loves you like unconditionally
she would say why is he muslim
why is he muscling it on my my gig is
what he's she's by the way yes what what
i would say to that is yeah
it's hers
she has to approve rich is all i'm
saying she's not that's like everything
else in my life i know uh that's the way
it goes no you have to well by the way
that's what you when you have a strong
woman next to you you've got to get
approval absolutely uh are you still
hanging out with bomber you still
chilling out with him by the way i went
opening night uh i had a nice
conversation with
my my friend your friend
it's bordering on friendship
he came over to my table at the season
ticket thing and he's like we talked for
a while okay uh his son sometimes opens
for me his son's a comedian
no kidding
there's no kidding a good kid does
bomber text in all caps he seems like an
old caps texter
by the way uh he does not okay but you
know what i want to say this i'm gonna
be i'm gonna i'm gonna do give a blanket
statement owners are
my favorite player on the clippers is
steve ballmer
come on
come on best owner first off rich's
owner in all of sports you know he has
only one partner you know only one other
person as any a smaller guy that he's
one of his best friends we went to
college with one person boom that's it
he only wants the team to be great he
respects and loves the fans right he is
the best owner in all of sports even
though i love the bulls i gotta give my
props to my la team the clippers love my
clippers but my favorite player is steve
ballmer bomber
all right jeff garland i love you bud um
let's do it i love you too let's do this
again next time in person okay i want to
see you all right let's do it hey uh
keep keep getting let me tell you
something else yes sir you make my life
a joy i feel you're the equivalent for
me
you are the complete opposite
of one of watching alex rodriguez on
sunday night
the pain that that causes me and the joy
that you caused me are the opposite of
the spectrum but the same intensity the
same intensity right it's the same
intensity same intensity and by the way
baseball right now you know
wait how are they getting young black
fans you need what you need to do is put
a great black broadcaster on all of them
and tell them to tell major league
baseball keep it under two and a half
hours what the hell are they doing jeff
garcia longest most boring baseball ever
i can keep going forever that's why i
want the whole segment at jeff garland
on instagram you take care brother take
care of yourself that's jeff garlin curb
your enthusiasm and also the goldbergs
right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here